- [Interviewer] All right, Royalty.
Royalty, where are you
from, where'd you grow up?
- [Royalty] I'm from
Kansas city, Missouri.
- [Interviewer] Kansas city.
And tell me about your family,
you had both your parents
when you were young?
- I was adopted, and I,
I had a mom and a dad, yeah.
But they had separated.
- [Interviewer] So, the family
that adopted you broke up?
- Yeah, they separated, and
then I was like back and forth,
and then in my teenage years,
I kinda just was on my own.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- It was lonely.
- [Interviewer] Were you the only child?
- No, no.
I was just, I kinda like,
programmed my mind into
thinking that, like,
it was like me against the world and stuff
because of like a situation
that had happened.
And like,
the reason why I went
to foster care and stuff
was because my mom had left me on a porch,
and it kinda just symbolized a lot for me
and I kinda use that situation
a lot of times in my life,
you know, and I just have
always had the mindset that,
you know no one loves me
and I'll never love anybody
and that's just the way it is.
And I just now am changing that mindset.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you now?
- I'm 18, yeah, I just turned 18 in April.
- [Interviewer] And how,
so you've been working
Figueroa Street?
- I work different places,
I don't just work Fig,
I honestly don't really like Fig
because it's a lot of gang banging
and just a lot of fuckery (laughing).
Unnecessary.
- [Interviewer] And you've
been doing this for how long?
- I've been doing this for a year.
- [Interviewer] So, you work
with the pamper by yourself?
- I prefer not to say.
- [Interviewer] Okay. And yeah, yeah.
So, how much money do you
think you make on average?
- I'd prefer not to say.
- [Interviewer] Okay. That's fine.
(both laughing)
Understood.
And so, you're living with your,
do you have a boyfriend or
somebody that you stay with?
- I prefer not to say
that either (laughing),
but I do have an apartment.
- Okay.
- Yeah,
I just moved inside of my apartment.
- So you left home,
back to your childhood,
you left home at what age?
- I left home when I was about 15.
- [Interviewer] 15, and
where'd you go at 15?
- I had a boyfriend and
he was like, really,
you know like my boyfriend,
I guess you could say,
and I lived with him for three years
and then the day that I left him,
I like started hoeing, so.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And
that was in Kansas city?
- No, this was in San Diego.
- San Diego.
- I moved to San Diego when I was 12.
- [Interviewer] With your family?
- With my mom.
- With your mom, okay.
Do you remember the
first time you did this,
worked as a prostitute?
- Yeah.
- What was it,
what was the first time like?
- It was, it was, it was
funny (laughing), because.
I had just left my
little boyfriend's house,
and I was in downtown San Diego,
and this guy, he kept following
me around and I was like,
what the hell like, I'm not
really feeling it, you know?
Like, this is weird.
'Cause I was like 17 but I was used to
guys doing that though,
because I had been approached
to engage in prostitution,
but I had always tried
to stay away from it
because I was like, no,
like it's not that serious for me.
But that day I was like, you know,
you ain't got that many options here.
And so he was like, "Are
you tryna make some money?"
And I was like,
"I'm not really like a
prostitute like that."
And he just kinda convinced
me into doing it, so I did it,
and then I just never stopped after that.
- [Interviewer] It's fast money.
Have you ever had a real
job? Like a straight job?
Square job?
- I never had a real job.
- [Interviewer] Did you
have dreams as a kid
of doing anything?
- Yes.
- Like what?
- Like, I really liked law
and I liked to read and stuff.
Like, I wanted to be like a teacher,
and a lawyer, and a psychiatrist,
i had a lot of dreams.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you
finished high school?
- No, I dropped out when
I was like in 10th grade.
Yeah. But I loved school, school was fun.
- [Interviewer] So did
somebody, do you have friends
that did this, that
got you into this game?
- No, you know me.
- You figured it out.
- I'm very antisocial,
like seriously (laughing).
I just talk like to tricks,
like tricks or like the
only people that I talk to
outside of my close circle,
because that's just the way that I am.
So, everything that I learned,
it's pretty much by myself.
- [Interviewer] And so,
the money that you make,
do you give to your, somebody?
- I prefer not to say.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You had any
bad experiences out there?
- Aha.
I got some really bad experience.
- [Interviewer] Already?
You're young yeah.
- I'm glad that I've had them now already
because.
- What's happened?
- I've been raped and
I've almost gotten killed,
and they happened like in the same week,
which was like definitely
a wake up call for me,
on a different.
I mean, I wasn't like,
"Oh, I'm gonna stop,"
because I was like, "You
ain't got nothing else to do."
But I was like, the way that you do it,
like, I'm very strict.
I'm more strict now
when it comes.
- I interrupted you,
you were saying, you're
glad that it happened,
so that, now that you're more aware?
- Oh yeah, because the first time,
it was like a black guy
and I didn't wanna date him
because I knew that you
weren't supposed to.
But he was just like really popping at it,
and I was like, okay, fuck it.
So, I got in his car.
And it's fucked up because this was like,
when Black Lives Matter was
popping, and I was like,
"You know, I really hope that, you know,
"you just take care of me, you know,
"like a good brother should," (laughing).
And he like, just pulled out a knife,
like to my throat and he was
just like, yeah, you know,
"Get in the back."
And I was like, "Please don't kill me."
You know, and he just
did what he had to do.
But the only thing that
I can be thankful for
is that he had the audacity
to put a condom on,
that's the only thing that
I could be thankful for.
And I was just crying,
and I was like, you know,
this is fucked up,
and I guess he just came to
his senses and he was like
"Just get the fuck out my car."
And then like a couple of days later,
I had did this date with this Mexican man,
and I was like very naive.
And so, I think I had like
a little bit of my money
like in the case of my phone,
and this nigga it took it,
and i was like not feeling it, I was like
"Hold up, run that back though,"
because that's fucked up.
And so, I had tried to like manipulate him
and be like, "Oh, I'm a minor,
"and if you don't give me this back,"
and I was just like really dumb.
And he started driving me somewhere,
and I was like really feeling
myself and thinking that
like he was gonna give me.
'Cause he gave me my money
back, but then I was like
being greedy and I wanted more.
And he just drove me
to this side of, I don't remember,
but, and he just started choking me out,
and like punching me.
And it was like the worst thing
that's ever happened to me,
it was terrible, I thought
I was really gonna die,
like as a prostitute at 18.
I was like, "This is some bullshit."
And I was really praying
and I was trying to use
all the physical force that I had,
and I was using my words,
like I was, you know,
really saying some shit so I could get him
to lay the fuck off, you know what I mean?
And he finally did, like,
he threw me out the car
and when he was done that looked like
somebody sliced my neck
with, like with a whole butcher knife.
But he really just choked me though,
that's how crazy it was.
And it's crazy, cause I saw him again.
Like on Long Beach, I saw him
and he thought I was a
different girl (sobbing).
- Oh really?
- It was fucked up.
I was like, "wow."
- [Interviewer] And you
didn't go to the police
the first time?
- No.
I didn't go-
- Because,
because of what you do, you you
feel like you can't do that?
- I mean, i just feel like
they don't give a fuck,
and yeah (laughing).
They don't give a fuck, and it's just like
I didn't have a license plate or nothing.
If I did, then I would have, you know.
Because I'm pretty sure he's
done that to other girls,
but I didn't have any of that information,
so I was like, "Imma just thug it out."
- [Interviewer] Are drugs
a part of your life.
- Yeah, I mean I'm not anymore,
but I've had some problems.
Ever since I was like young,
I just always wanted to be
like intoxicated in some way.
But now I have somebody in my life
that is like my anti-drug.
So I know I don't need
to do that shit anymore.
- [Interviewer] Okay. That's good for you.
- Yeah.
- Do you still have contact
with your family?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do they
know you're doing this?
- Mh hm.
- They do?
- I just like talked to
my mom and my dad today,
and I was like, "Yeah, I got pink hair,"
and they were like, "Oh, that's nice."
They don't like it like at all,
but they just are glad
that I'm alive, I guess.
- Did those experiences that
week where you, you know,
may have escaped death, does
it slow you down from doing it
or make you re reconsider?
- I mean, I don't really have
that option to just stop,
cold turkey.
- You need the money.
- Right.
I wish I woulda, 'cause
when I was like young,
this shit was fun and
I could just come out
and like I was like really turned on
by the fact that I could
make hundreds of dollars,
like, that young, you know,
'cause that's not normal.
And, I just got addicted to it,
and now I'm just like,
it's just got bills to pay,
you know, and all this, this and that,
and it's kinda just
like, it's really a job,
like it's really a job.
And I just wish that I would realize that,
but it is what it is.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry,
I can edit this together.
Do you get depressed sometimes?
This get you down?
- Not really.
- No?
- I mean, not really. No.
- [Interviewer] And
you're in love right now?
- No (laughing).
I'm not in love (laughing).
I'm not in love, I just.
I just have someone in my life
who has showed me something
that every other man hasn't,
but it's not like.
I mean, I guess you could
say I am, I don't know.
(giggling)
Yeah, I guess so.
But I mean, it's just because
he's a different type of breed.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I mean,
do you find it difficult
to live this lifestyle
where everybody around you
is kind of up to no good,
and they're all doing
something illegal or devious?
You know.
- I mean, no, because like
at the end of the day,
I'm like not, like I'm a
good girl, like I'm not.
And I like school and I like
books and like all that.
- [Interviewer] But
you're surrounded by guys
cheating on their wives and.
- Yeah.
- Pimps and drug dealers.
- But I mean, it doesn't
change who I am though,
I don't really, like I
said, I keep to myself,
so all of that that goes on, you know,
I don't really have
nothing to do with that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And so you don't feel
like you can walk away?
- Um, not right now.
- Yeah.
- No.
- [Interviewer] Just
for financial reasons?
- I mean, like,
that and multiple other things,
like this is just all I know right now,
and yeah.
- [Interviewer] You would
just stand back and look at
this lifestyle that you're living and go,
"Man, this is dangerous,
it's crazy, It's, yeah,
"I could be in jail?"
- Yeah, like,
there's been some fucked
up shit happening lately
and I've been like, "Bro,
"I'm really not (laughing).
"I'm really not feeling it."
. But it's just like,
(sirens wailing)
I don't know.
I have to continue to stay
strong and do what I gotta do.
(sirens wailing)
- [Interviewer] Do you have any friends?
Do you have any good friends?
- No, I don't have any friends.
- No?
- Nah (laughing).
- [Interviewer] That
makes it hard too, right?
- No, that's like really
how I naturally am.
I'm just,
I'm a loner I guess you could say.
I don't mind though.
- [Interviewer] Had you been arrested?
- I've gotten two tickets.
- [Interviewer] They just
give you tickets now,
they don't really?
- Yeah, they gave me two tickets.
I had, I went to court or whatever,
and it was like a DA
reject, it's just bullshit.
- And what do you think, like
the the men that pick you up,
do you find that
you're losing respect for men
because of the kind of guys
that you're interacting with?
- I mean, to me I'm always,
like a trick, it's like a
different type of breed to me.
Like, I don't categorize
them as like a man.
I know that's fucked up.
- No, it's probably not.
- But it's like, it's true because,
they really are like,
they'll pick up anything
and they really don't have
like no sense of like,
you know, like tricks are
really just cockroaches to me,
but they give me what I
need and I survive that way,
so, it is what it is.
But I mean, I don't really allow
the fuckery that they'd be
on, till like, you know,
be like, "Oh, men ain't shit,"
because that's just them, you know.
They're really like a
whole nother different type
of breed of men (laughing).
- [Interviewer] And the
guys you pick up are,
so you steer away from the black men.
- Oh yeah, I don't date
black guys, I don't know.
No, I'm good off of that.
- [Interviewer] And so
it's mostly Hispanics and-
- Yeah, but they'll kill you
too, which is the crazy part.
- I think they're all capable.
- So, it don't mean,
but it's just easier
because the black guys,
like black guys, they
just be doing the most,
they can never just have a
simple blowjob or fuck like ever.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] And what
do you get excited about?
What makes you happy?
- Seeing the people that
I care about being happy.
- [Interviewer] And do you have any goals,
what'd you like to do with your life?
Five, 10 years, where'd you like to be?
Married with kids?
- No.
- Going to school?
- Going to school sounds great.
Yeah, that sounds great.
- [Interviewer] You're
still very young yet, so.
- Yeah (laughing).
- So, what's your family's reaction
when you tell them what you're doing?
- You know what, I never
really got to tell them
because I started doing
it when I was a minor
and I was always getting
picked up, like by the police.
And you know, they're
obviously gonna tell,
like, you know, your daughter
was on the blade (laughing).
So, my mom kinda figured
out from law enforcement.
So, I never really got to
like break it down to her.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
You must have learned
something in the street life,
I mean, your intuition must be heightened
just because you're
interacting with strangers.
- It is.
Basically, just to like
never be comfortable.
Like, I'm just never
comfortable with anyb-
I have one person,
that like I can see that I trust.
- A regular?
- And that's it.
No (laughing). No.
Just one singular person,
and it's just like
everybody else, you know,
I'm looking at you sideways,
because I don't know you.
And even when I had met this person,
I was looking at them sideways,
because that's just how I am naturally,
and then with this street
shit, it like heightened it
to a major level.
But it protects my energy,
and it protects my heart,
so I don't have a problem with it.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Royalty, thank you so much for coming in
and sharing your story with me.
- Okay (laughing).
- Very interesting.
I wish you the best of luck, I hope you.
What's your goal, make a lot of money?
- I mean, it's really not
about the money to me,
like the money is always
gonna come, you know, that's.
- Do you find it fun?
- That's mando.
No, it's not fun to me.
- No,?
- No.
(giggling)
- [Interviewer] All right.
Well thank you so much.
- Okay, thank you.